hello welcome to a new episode of what
the hell am I gonna call this show today
I'm just straight out of the dungeon of
ask God please don't yell up vote for
geez
let's get into some programming humor
what do we got it's been a while
maybe there's something new why is my
green screen suck quiet just and why is
my jet was this inside out you gets a
style it's a style okay I need to be
different trying to be actually put it
on it inside out accidentally and I just
left it because let's not talk about
that it's not what this is about
okay we're gonna review some program or
humor if you relate to any of these you
win and you just you gotta keep watching
that's the rule let's just get let's
just get into it
HTML programmers I love this so they
posted some new rules submission content
must be creative or original thank you
intended humorously and strictly related
to programming yes
this is our cup of tea now ah okay
competition winners I oh yeah I guess
this is the new that's kind of a cool
logo alright
congratulations say grins oh seven with
your zeroth place in the array good job
you win can we get a round of applause
press alt f4 to pay respects plus plus
my isn't - - that's new that's really
cool the pain of CSS makes small change
in CSS my site uh I'm not relating to
that I get it I get the joke but like so
it's not very funny this is the most
uploaded one this is where we're
starting oh yeah just build me this app
bro it shouldn't take that long okay
I'll will bite there's nothing this is
it
there's no further context to this
that's not why did what is happening
here this isn't funny at all like yeah
we've all heard that but it's not like
top upvoted on the subreddit funny what
is there no good humor hope is not all
lost something is left here what it
feels like working with JavaScript you
are undefined you are undefined stripped
right everybody is undefined thumbs up
this video because I might make another
one if you do it needs expensive books
when you have Hungarians god bless home
Guardians
quicksort it's six minutes long it's
kind of long this is probably a lot more
entertaining at 2x speed I don't want to
learn quicksort again I already learned
it and forgot it like three times
long live successful people unsuccessful
evil people who create jsfiddle x' just
encode pins for others let's not let
non-programmers hear this word cuz
they're gonna think we're all like into
some really weird old you get that you
get that new thing from jsfiddle like oh
god who's that is that jesus fiddles
does it does he play the fiddle is there
a band is that a band the [ __ ] is
jsfiddle i'm not even gonna look I don't
want that in my browser history okay a
level computer science level computer
science please enter to choose number 12
to teen what is happening to teen okay
what people love this Pikachu was zoomed
in on pixelated and pixelated Pikachu
this feature would take three minutes
too much don't listen when we mean
feature full of bugs manager yeah well
what do you expect
Emacs verse bye oh god do we have to do
this do we have to do this what's the
stupidest thing you have to read that
it's obviously fake but people still
believe the Bible religious texts in
general including that sa postulate that
Emacs is better than Phi
you
I'm trying to I'm trying to get humor
out of this that's what I'm doing here
that's why I'm stared so long I'm trying
to it's just not it's just not funny
do I have is it me they say if you walk
into a room and everyone else is the
[ __ ]
maybe that means you're the [ __ ]
maybe if I look at all these posts and
none of them seem funny maybe I'm not
funny
you
wait why is this funny who cares
God to him I'm doing it again this is
gonna be the repeat of last video just
found this gym on our ass credit servers
what's the weirdest most alarming thing
you've overheard from one of your tables
there has to be an SQL joke in here
somewhere
yeah what is it though come on come on
what is it's gonna be yeah I don't know
inner join SQL jokes waiter jokes
mentioning tables needs some kind of
context in this video other than me
giggling like a high teenager I and my
GF live in SF we want to meet my gf
family in Seattle my GF dad is principal
engineer at MSFT Lucius Fatah Microsoft
it was it was dinner time we started
with casual conversation about tech jobs
and stuff from there we started talking
about interview processes and out of
nowhere he asked me how I would solve an
array question this is epic initially
okay he acted like it was a casual
conversation but I couldn't see how he
was evaluating my answer after all I
have years of LC experience what is LC
level control Learning Center liquid
crystal I don't what this was day to
shine
I started answering with brute force
solution following byte followed by
optimal solution talked about time and
space complexity in the end he was
somewhat satisfied okay well I still
wonder what the question is they are
asking us to visit again during
Christmas break I wonder if I should
prayer prepare for a system design girls
Asian I'm not this is to be expected
this is this isn't funny well what did
you expect what did you expect
what's LC leek toad porting doom my
favorite quasi meme phenomenon is
porting doom'd to devices that should
not reasonably be expected to run doom
that sounds really fun is it funny why
is this on programmer humor I don't know
it's not it's cool it's cool it's
programmer cool a lot of these are
actually kind of cool but that's maybe
we need a new subreddit have we
discovered something new
dear JavaScript truck stop trying to be
Java some code you'll never beat Java
this happens more often than I like when
you get one big bug in your program and
after hours of testing and searching on
Google you still can't fix it till you
try something really simple and dumb and
suddenly it works and you feel like an
idiot
returning to cyber life for deactivation
what is an algorithm why they're so
important for computers can we see the
rest for the Bill Clinton rhythm if you
know what I mean he's being super serial
gas because he invented the Internet duh
per second my god these are ok
despite their new rules and their
attempts at humor we got some work to do
that's you know just it's gonna be ok
did you relate did you where's my camera
did you relate you what about you did I
I think I sorta related to one so I'd
say like I almost almost won and I don't
have to edit this video that would be a
great price actually I'd go for that
price but I did relate so I guess I got
it edit the video ah see you next time